hey what is up everybody it's animak
here for anime uproar and today i will
be breaking down the secret history of
flame breathing one of the most
important and most powerful breathing
styles in the demon slayer story i will
be discussing its secret origins all of
its known users and its amazing
abilities if you'd like me to make a
similar video for all the other
breathing styles let me know by leaving
a like and comment and i will be happy
to do it ten thousand likes and one
thousand comments will unlock the next
video if you enjoy the demonstrator
content here on the channel don't forget
to subscribe we already have a huge and
growing demon slayer playlist you can
check that out link in the description
and if you don't want to miss future
videos definitely subscribe hit that
bell and then select the option that
says all if you don't go through all of
those steps you're still gonna miss a
ton of our videos even if you are
subscribed it's just how youtube works
now before we get into it i have to give
a huge shout out to our partner
aitaikuji itaikuji is an online retailer
in japan that makes anime merch that is
normally exclusive to japan available to
fans all over the world they have a huge
selection of awesome anime merch
straight from japan including an entire
section on demon slayer which has some
of the best demonstrator merch i've ever
seen including figurines clothing and
much more check them out link in the
description and because we're partnered
with them you can now use the coupon
code anime opera 500 for an instant
discount every time you use the coupon
code you are not only getting awesome
merch at a discounted price but you are
also directly supporting demons player
and this channel at the same time so
check them out link in the description
quick warning that this video will
contain some spoilers for demon slayer
so please proceed with caution you have
been warned so as the name suggests
flame breathing is a breathing style
centered around the properties of fire
and flames this breeding style uses
movements and techniques that are
inspired by the behavior of flames and
this style is centered around swift and
powerful strikes of the sword flame
breathing users have produced a hashida
in every single generation since the
style first emerged so the position of
flame hashida has a long and highly
respected history water breathing is the
only other style that shares this honor
so it is safe to say that historically
flame breathing has one of the most
important and most powerful breathing
styles but what is flame breathing and
how did it come into existence in the
first place it was actually the former
flame hashira shinjuru rengoku who
revealed to tanjiro that every single
breathing style originated from a single
style called sun breathing or breath of
the sun sun breathing was the first
breathing style and it was created by
the legendary demon slayer yorichi
tsugikuni a man who lived about 400
years before the beginning of the demon
slayer story thanks to his ability to
use sun breathing yorichi is the man who
came the closest to killing muzon and he
was the only person muzon feared but
because yorichi didn't finish muzon off
the demons continued to exist and they
continued to pose a threat to the
innocent people of japan yorichi knew
that this demon threat would persist
even after his death so he decided to
teach other demon slayers to use the
breath of the sun in order to keep up
the fight against muzon and his demons
unfortunately yorichi's students were
not able to fully grasp the power of sun
breathing so yurichi had to adjust the
breath of the sun to fit the abilities
of his students one of these students
became the first user of flame breathing
flame breathing is essentially a less
powerful offshoot of sun breathing and
this breeding style was passed on from
generation to generation for over four
centuries until it was inherited by the
current members of the rengoku family
but the story of flame breathing does
not end there just as flame breathing
itself was derived from sun breathing
once that original breathing style was
modified to suit the needs of yorichi
student mitsuri kandra ji's love
breathing style is derived from flame
breathing that kyoji orengoku had taught
her love breathing is a style unique to
mitsuri and it is an alteration of flame
breathing designed to take advantage of
her unusual physique and especially her
unique muscle density and so flame
breathing is not only a derivative of
sun breathing but it itself can also be
the foundation of other derivative
styles like love breathing flame
breathing has nine unique forms but only
six of them are known at this time
these include first form unknowing fire
an attack that involves the user
charging their opponent and swinging
their blade with the attempt to
decapitate the enemy second form rising
scorching sun which is an upward slash
attack third form blazing universe which
is an arched upward slash fourth form
blooming flame undulation which involves
the user spinning their sword rapidly in
order to defend from enemy attacks fifth
form flame tiger which involves multiple
sword slashes that form the shape of a
tiger and finally ninth form rengoku a
fiery slash from a distance that has the
power to obliterate everything in sight
this ninth form is said to be unique to
the members of the rengoku family
personally i would love to know more
about the first flame breathing user and
how flame breathing came to be a staple
of the rengoku family in particular but
unfortunately the absolute mad lad
shinjuru rengoku the father of kyojiro
destroyed the generational flame hashia
record of the rengoku family it is
important to note that kyojiro's father
shinjuro is a former flame hashira
himself and he was once extremely
dedicated and successful in his role as
a demon slayer in episode 1 of the
second season of the demon slayer anime
we meet an elderly woman who works as a
bento box vendor at a railway station we
eventually learned that 20 years before
the mugen train arc this same elderly
woman and her daughter were saved from a
demon by shinjuro and back then he
seemed to have been just as impressive
as his son kyojiro is today so much so
that the woman at first mistakes kyojiro
for his father but shinjuro was deeply
affected by the premature death of his
wife ruka and after this happened he
started drinking too much and he
eventually no longer wanted to be a
hashida he retired and he actively
discouraged both of his sons from
joining the demon slayer core however
his discouragement although mean and
brutal actually came from a good place
shinjuru knew how dangerous the life of
a demon slayer was and he wanted his
sons to stay away from that danger but
instead of being honest with them he
tried to bully and intimidate them into
following the path that he had chosen
for them and that plan failed miserably
since we know that kyojiro eventually
became the new flame hashira if you want
to know more about the life of kyoto in
particular i already made an entire 20
minute video talking about him and his
backstory i will link it in the
description and in the pinned comment
and that is everything that we know
about flame breathing in demon slayer
again if you want to see me make a
similar video on the other breathing
styles leave a like and also comment
which breathing style you want me to do
next 10 000 likes at 1 000 comments
unlocks the next video don't forget that
here at anime opera we have a huge and
growing demon slayer video playlist and
more videos are coming soon so
definitely subscribe hit that bell and
then select the option that says all you
can also hit me up on twitter and
instagram at animeopror oh and one more
time don't forget to check out our
partner itaikuji use the promo code
animeopro 500 for an instant discount
and support demonstrator and this
channel at the same time check them out
link in the description and in the
pinned comment i want to give a quick
thank you to all of our anime uproar
patrons who make videos like this one
possible special thank you to alpha
sigma this man is an absolute mad lad
and a disciple of lord twigo himself and
i can't forget all of our the one tier
patrons the ones who stand above all
other clans including ingrata pate heffa
algetal hinokamian water the toasted chi
the spike corey mcgowan kaido might be a
gyarados dylan isidor spidey life tinel
tungsten tarkis big buddhist cody hebert
monkey d quilly and jeremy cummings
finally thank you also to our pro hero
tier patrons including the one and only
gilgamesh the red haired raven angel
crews rather indiora very gucci alicia
actor bonnie parks joy and garcia ted no
ted and fat boy games if you enjoy our
videos and you feel that they provide
value to you consider supporting us on
patreon even a single dollar will give
you access to our patron exclusive
discord and your name will appear in our
videos along with these amazing people
as always thank you guys so much for
watching and until next time see ya
space cowboys
[Music]
you